[Music]
in hidden family news oh [ __ ]
submitted by rush hour 10 a family was
rescued after living in captivity for
nine years waiting for the end of time
oh wait what night and year in captivity
yeah weather detective maybe it's like
the Kimmy Schmidt show when they were
being held against their will not
against their will but they were told
like the world is gonna end
yeah the one that's the premise of her
and then she goes on to the remember
those kids in New York they just
released that they all yeah made like
their own little movies and stuff they
were called like the wolf children or
some [ __ ] like that there's all these
brothers and sisters yeah lived in an
apartment I forgot their name in you're
sleeping yeah you're right there wasn't
getting but parents never let the kids
out because they were afraid of the
outside
yeah the dad was paranoid anyway so this
story here it all starts when a 25 year
old man was in desperate need of help
and so he ends up going to a pub and he
starts talking to the bars owner after
he got some drinks um
and so he had long tangled hair a dirty
beard and he was wearing tattered
clothing and appeared perpetually
confused and the bars owner said that
there was something unworldly about him
so then his smell I never smelled this
[ __ ] animal before he said that the
he was the oldest that he has siblings
or his family was that he was really
concerned for the way that they were
living and like he needed help and he
said that he managed to sneak out of a
small secret room where he and his adult
siblings had been kept all this time
which is the nine years living in
isolation in a farmhouse in the
Netherlands so
that's when he was able to get cops to
go and investigate and that's when they
were met by this 58 year old man
described as a handyman and he was
refusing to cooperate with the police so
the police arrested him and that's when
they discovered these adult-like kids
so initially they were saying that this
man wasn't related to these these people
but then later on they're saying that
they're he's their father so it's kind
of unclear there's mixed reports adult
children huh yeah from 18 to 25 so they
were being held when they were younger
yeah so for the last yeah how many
there's total of six six all walking
around with those little wind shoes 18
to 25 so that's a seven-year span so six
children in seven years that's crazy and
where's the mom in all of this they're
saying that the mom died before they
went like in isolation yeah so they get
kidnapped all of that so that's the
thing that's like they don't know how
they got there they're saying that
everything is really unclear like what
exactly happened in the farmhouse
they're just describing like the
neighbors saying that they just thought
this one man lived there alone
especially because he was renting this
farm please yeah and the owner thought
that she was just renting it to one man
and they're also describing that the
kids all six children that they weren't
registered with local authorities so
they technically a didn't exist for
anything maybe the dad killed the mom
and then he like had to isolate
everybody so they wouldn't get caught
but they were 18 at 25 and they've been
there for only nine years what happened
before that
did he because they were also the oldest
was 25 and the one that escaped Paul was
the Ford 19 1814 Oh but it's at the end
of the world that he make them think
that they were wait like the world's 16
right yeah also that's what they're
describing and like there's a lot of
headlines saying that this Dutch family
was waiting the end of times
so it just seemed like they were just
living there just to wait their death
waiting for the apocalypse ed dad's
gonna die first
well cuz the oldest one was 16 he
already knows like enough about the
world and all that [ __ ] so he unless
like he's been in cat captivity this
whole time he's not even registered with
the government though so maybe he
doesn't know anything
yeah but he only said that he's been
trapped there for nine years maybe in
that particular spot so you did say he
hadn't been to a barber I go to a barber
shop in nine years I like things like
that like Oh even been in the outside
world for you so they don't even know
what's happening on the outside so
they've been in that room yeah
oh it's boring it was this um they're
saying that there were like these
makeshift furniture cuz the 58 year old
man was like a handyman or carpenter or
something so I guess he built furniture
for them and like there was this one
like that well he cares for him the
secret room that had like makeshift
walls and stuff but I don't know and
everyone in this town is like shocked
cuz they're like how fun did the house
look though I don't know cuz if it was
like it could either go like rapey or
could either go like paradise paradise
yeah this is kind of Joe's dream is to
like it's a farmhouse you eat food all
day you don't got a were like self
esteem I mean yeah you're with family
and friends there's a mud hug I gotta do
[ __ ] why is that horrible I think it's
more horrible you gotta [ __ ] work you
gotta pay bills
I also think it's more horrible that
some people are watching this video
right now and they're not subscribed to
us that's terrible please subscribe
you're trapped in a house and someone
isn't letting you out subscribe to our
Channel and if you're trapped in a house
cuz you just maybe you don't have
friends to go out and play with like you
guys subscribe that's true we'll be your
friend so except for Joe Jordan one
beings
that's true maybe you guys Oh
maybe even me of course maybe maybe oh
[ __ ] he gave it city took it away of
course maybe this is like could you
imagine nine years ago and then you just
come back to the world and then they're
like Donald Trump is the President of
the United States you're like [ __ ] and
he goes back into the I don't know if
there was some context it's like wait
what is it a reality show now like in
this is in a White House reality
reference he knows it's like the guy
from home alone so 2010 he was doing
you're fired yeah yeah it's doing
apprentice so so he's like you mean the
guy from apprentice to the last
president he get fired yeah they didn't
even know hama
exactly and you imagine being like Time
Warp for 10 years all the [ __ ] that
happened within the last 10 years from
2009 to 2012 you when they come out
you're like the news yeah and then but
still not the same it's super literature
that's extremely limited they don't even
know about tick-tock Kent no more Gary
Vee oh my god I went to boot camp for
three and a half months and it's very
limited access to the world and I
remember the day I graduated and I when
I went back home it was like it just
felt like I was coming back it was time
portal yeah and it's only three and a
half months but it's just when you're
when you're not updated by all these
things you're like what hail vol has
another version it's just crazy
well you don't have to do a CD for
minutes anymore yeah it's like what the
[ __ ] that's crazy I know it's a trip so
they this family was taken to the doctor
and now they're being cared for and a
large scale investigation is ongoing so
prosecutors they will consider whether
criminal charges need to be brought in
the case we have a question so they're
evacuating these kids how are they gonna
live in society like if it's all they
know they're not even
register with the government how are
they gonna get a job they got extra
experience to like live work or like
sure the plug him into like some like
school system yeah and like the cycle
slowly start like having them assimilate
Dutch circus you know in the u.s. if you
don't have a social security number
because some parents elect for their
kids not like um Mormons
like very devout Mormons they elect to
not register their children with the
government or something and it can be
very difficult even if you're an adult
to finally get that so there's to be a
citizen to pretty thank you yeah like
you can't prove that you're American you
can't prove they get it birth
certificates
no but there's a whole process - that's
the thing there's not a process to
figure it out yeah cuz what the
Hillbillies do yes they in the woods
issue it affects most is hillbillies my
parents are like yeah they're off the
grid mm-hmm but they're American like
they've been here for so many
generations but if they're in an ice
rink
yep don't know where they're sending you
but that's true no where do you go I
don't know that's true they're like
you're an amateur stayin here they're
like yeah how do they process them they
send you to the country that you looked
at your friends
you look Mexican you go there you go
Scotland Scottish yeah what if you don't
tell them what country you're from oh
yeah because I feel like they would send
me to more like like a Latin country
rather than an Asian country because I
look more like that no so I heard like
the whole social security theme where
like in the 60s it was actually pretty
freakin easy because there were a lot of
people that didn't have it so they could
just go to the Social Security building
and just get their thing and normally
questioned it he also had driver's
license that were like out of paper and
then they just kind of laminated it a
little bit yeah and I think that's why
like illegal immigration and things like
that back then was just it was less
controlled and it was much more easier
for people to just come in and then
become citizens and stuff that's pretty
crazy though
Real ID to go on a plan like they didn't
have to wear seatbelts back then they
were like we don't know how cars work if
you had a chance to get like a expat and
being like citizens somewhere else would
you do it yeah you would wear cuz I love
being right yeah I feel like it's just
it's so hard to get in but we're good
but when you're ballin you can be
American anywhere what
Pacquiao has an entire army with
thousands of guns in the Philippines so
what's the American part of that I don't
even know if anyone else has guns
but do you but like when you when you
have money you could bend all the rules
of any nation of innocence yeah but
those guys get jacked by the government
though I'll do this yeah how much money
then
yeah like media the government sees them
as like a threat cuz they're getting too
much power and then they'll come in and
it'll just take all your [ __ ] that's why
he's a senator yeah yeah so good simile
where Pat Cal you're like Filipino Jesus
so that's that's true yeah it's it's
yeah so you need a talent and a lot of
money yeah you're [ __ ] we're not too
much oh don't be like a billionaire you
like see you don't America Vegas be nice
[Music]